اشكاليه السوريه
تبعت
الاكس
[موسيقى]
عوده سوريا
عوده في سياق
ساعه عربي لتسهيل تسويه الوضع السوري
نسميه الوضع السوري سميه الاشكاليه
السوريه
والحكومه السوريه والحكم في سوريا قابل
بان تكون هذه العوده في سياق بحث في كيفيه
وبالتالي في كيفيه
وبالتالي العرب طرحوا نفسهم
اساسا
لمساعد للحكومه السوريه
للتوصل الى بر الامان
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس الى مدينه
جده
[موسيقى]
الاجتماعات على مستويات متعدده نتحدث عن
مستويات اقتصاديه وايضا سياسيه لوضع ابرز
الملفات التي تهم كافه الدول العربيه
لمناقشتها على طاوله القاده حيث الملفات
السياسيه الاكثر الحاحا وتحدث عن الازمه
في السودان من جانبيها السياسي وكذلك
الانساني التي سيتم طرحها بقوه يوم غد
لمناقشتها على كافه الاصعده بالاضافه الى
مناقشه ملفات سياسيه متعدده منها اليمن
والهدنه في اليمن والمحاولات
لايقاف الحرب هنالك والانتقال الى مفاوضات
يمنيه يمنيه برعايه وبواساطه سعوديه وايضا
الدوليه بالاضافه الى ذلك سيكون هنالك
ايضا
ملفات اخرى يتم الحديث عن فلسطين
والتصعيد الاسرائيلي الاخير بالاضافه الى
ازمات اخرى تعلق بالمياه